moi ce qui m'est arrivé je vous dis
pendant les vacances je suis allé aux
états unis je suis allé aux états unis
je suis à la new york et les chérubins
ça s'est pas passé comme je le voulais
sachez que je j'ai passé 12 heures à
l'aéroport de new york
je suis arrivé à new york et on n'était
qu'un pote jean rachid on n'a mis que
vous connaissez et on est arrivé à new
york
et donc c'est vrai que on a passé la
douane et donc le mec arrive ils
commencent à nous interroger bon c'est
vrai que l'anglais faut savoir que je
parle cent fois mieux anglais que mon
ami déjà le niveau du gua donc on arrive
hélas deux quintes il faut les deux la
iame à jimmy fallon une french jimmy
fallon est l'hôte et google lysozyme
kong nesim est donc voilà on arrive aux
questions fait là bas on est venu en
vacances quoi comme ça quoi pour vous
êtes devenu son bagage ouais parce qu'en
fait on est pareils on a aimé que des si
vous avez s'il était venu avec deux sacs
donc on pas on va alors ils vont aller
mais nous dans le bureau les deux on
arrive dans le bureau et là le gars fait
tout va bien vous inquiétez pas ce que
le mec est super saab a été un
alors pourquoi vous êtes venu si peu
comme ça recoupe pour faire des du
chopper quoi basket show cette claquette
claquettes chaussettes commence à
décoller tout le mec qui d'après mes
lots toujours comme les i
jimmy fallon il fait le guet ouais c est
donc le gard donc il dit non mais oui
c'est où on est très sympa on est resté
deux heures avec le gars il dit pourquoi
vous êtes là qu'est ce que vous avez
fait et pourquoi vous allez venir
pourquoi toujours là après il nous
laisse partir là on fait 50 m il ya un
autre gars qui fait là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vivable cependant les dollars
comme il ya tout là mais on est mal
will come with the maréchaussée quoi on
dit ouais comme il a recommandé un
relais de l'allée de l'es2 quand ils
arrivent ils fouillent naussac
qu'est-ce que j'ai acheté appareil à
l'aéroport vous savez que je suis fan de
crimes de crimes de trucs comme ça dit
équipe et j'ai acheté deux revues une
revue d'effectif et nous revenons à
marquer en et non criminelle
[Applaudissements]
il appelle car il arrive comme ça ils
appellent tous les tons que depuis hier
mon pote jean rachid rien un éclair lui
fait c'est un pote offres mobiles je
suis producteur de films donc je
m'inspire de chez huawei et tout est là
il remet la phrase beaucoup ici et là le
gars à membres éliront je vais le google
il est donc qui gogh ou lisent et vous
jean rachid le long way c'est lui qui me
disent moi et donc il y prendront pas ce
soir et on va mobiliser c'est vrai toit
way away est donc là les gars super
sympathique
du coup on a pris un petit verre avec
quelques jours après mon du tube you
come back when you et de ou donc on à
rester parce que il ya eu deux heures de
tanner et 2h d'arc à l'aéroport dit
mitch contrôler les gens de venir black
oui vous avez trois un ter
c'est pour ça
[Applaudissements]
merci jean michel mr s'entremêlent
ventre et merci
[Rires]
l'arrivée
jouer au lia